hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
fossil fuels now
painters as climate clemat's meter
P makes 4 billion pounds in the first
quarter of the Year beating forecasts
[Music]
primary school children will celebrate
the coronation by planting Wildflower
Meadows
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now representatives from over 40
countries are in Berlin for major
climate talks hosted by the German
government the Petersburg climate
dialogue is designed to lay the
groundwork for cop28 in Abu Dhabi later
this year well our Europe correspondent
Siobhan Robbins is outside that meeting
in Berlin she joins us now what's been
happening there today Siobhan
so this is the first day of a two-day
meeting which is really seen as a very
important stop on the journey towards
cop 28 which of course will be held in
November by the United Arab Emirates and
among the 40 countries or so that are
here today there are big emitters
including the U.S China and India and
many of the things that will be
discussed in this meeting are things
that will then be Revisited in cop28 so
things for example like how are we doing
in boosting the use of Renewables how
are we doing on meeting those pledges
that were agreed in the Paris climate
agreement and of course looking at our
use of fossil fuels and particularly
around the phasing out of fossil fuels
now while some say they need to be
totally phased out others are using far
more nuanced language take a listen to
the president of cop28
we know that the energy is used today
will continue to be part of the global
Energy Mix for the foreseeable future
and as such we will continue to work
with the world to decarbonize the
current Energy System while we build the
new Energy System
speaking there but why is there such
controversy about him and the many roles
that he has
well one of one of the main issues when
he was announced as president of comp 28
is the fact that he's an oil executive
but I think this language today around
fossil fuels is also something that's
concerning climate activists because
rather than talking about phasing out
fossil fuels he's been talking about
decarbonizing the current system so
activists are concerned essentially
what's being discussed here is
potentially using Technologies like
carbon capture to capture the emissions
which then some could use as an excuse
to extend the life of fossil fuels and
extend the extraction for example of oil
and climate activists have told us that
would be an absolute disaster
will continue to engage with the
co-president about what we would want to
see as an outcome at cop28 and that is
you know being very clear not with vague
language that we do want to see a just
and Equitable phase out of fossil fuels
all fossil fuels
so still really challenging debates to
be had and no agreement Insight on
issues at a time when we're told we're
still failing to properly tackle this
climate crisis
okay Siobhan thank you so much
right well let's take a look at some of
the other stories making the news today
and primary school children will receive
more than 200 000 packets of wildflower
seeds to plant in celebration of the
coronation the scheme is being run by
the government and cornwall's Eden
Project is part of a plan to create 40
hectares of new Wildflower Meadows in
England to support pollinating insects
in the U.S the coastal city of Virginia
Beach was hit with its most powerful
tornado ever over the weekend sending
residents fleeing for cover the Twister
ripped roofs from buildings and homes
from their foundations as destructive
storms hit the U.S east Coast from north
to south
and climate protests hit the Met Gala
last night temporarily blocking a car
carrying Paris Hilton the demonstrators
carried banners accusing the wealthiest
one percent of the population of being
disproportionately responsible for
climate change
now the oil giant BP announced another
bumper profit today making about four
billion pounds in the first quarter of
this year significantly ahead of
forecasts so let's speak to our business
presenter Ian King so Ian another
lucrative quarter for them yes that's
right Kimberly on an underlying basis
basic BP made a replacement cost profit
which is the industry's preferred
measure of five billion dollars during
the first three months of this year that
was actually down from the 6.2 billion
dollars that it recorded in the same
period last year but it was up from 4.8
billion dollars in the final three
months of 2022 and what is significant
about that in particular is that the oil
price has actually been falling in the
final uh three months of last year it
was averaging around 88 to 87 a barrel
in the first three months of this year
Brent crude was averaging 81.17 a barrel
so they've increased their profits
despite the fact that the oil price has
fallen have they done that well
essentially it's down to uh what the
company itself calls an exceptional
performance in oil and gas fast trading
and that's really uh what shot the
lights out this time around it's worth
pointing out the share price has traded
it between five and six percent lower
today at various points because it's
also paired back it's share buy back
Ambitions for the year
okay and you know they are being
criticized aren't they for scaling back
their climate pledges yes they are I
think you have to put this into context
Kimberly if you compare what the likes
of BP and shell and total the big
European oil and gas majors are
announcing compared with their U.S peers
the likes of Chevron and Exxon well they
are still being incredibly uh ambitious
in terms of their emissions reduction
but if you take what BP was originally
uh hoping to do it was looking to reduce
its emissions uh by 2030 uh by some 40
from the 2019 level it's actually uh
revised that recently down to 25
reduction that has got some shareholders
hot under the collar and indeed uh the
company has actually had to uh face uh
calls from some investors for its
chairman to step down hoga Lund uh in
amid unhappiness about that although as
I say you have to put it in context BP
is still being pretty ambitious in terms
of its emissions reduction proposals
compared with its American peers okay
Ian thank you so much
right that's all from us today thank you
so much for watching join us again on
the daily climate show tomorrow at the
same time I'll see you then
foreign